Before going any further, let's put some
module level variables into our code.
We can see these are pretty
straight forward.
The first one is just the tag
that we're going to be using, and
the tag is just the string with the
details of the application that you're
going to use for logging.
Then we're going to create a Google API
client, called mGoogleApiClient,
a location object that we call
mLastLocation, a text view object,
that we call mLatitudeText, and
another text view object,
that we call mLongitudeText.
So next up, what we need to do
is update the onCreate function.
We're going to create it to set the
content view, get a reference to each of
our views, and then finally
build the Google API client.
Let's see what that looks like.
So here's the code.
I'm just again, creating a text view
by finding the latitude text and
setting that to my latitude text,
text view.
And then ditto with the longitude text,
finding the item,
cast it to a text view and
assigning it to longitude text.
And then I've written a helper
function called buildGoogleApiClient.
As you can see, it's red right now.
That's okay, it's just because I
haven't actually implemented this yet.
We'll do that in the next step.